الطريق الى خرسون غيره امن من هنا بدات
القوات الروسيه بالمغادره لكن القصفها
للمدينه لا يتوقف
اثار عتاد الروسي ينبا بهول ما جرح الدمار
في كل مكان
تتدافع صور الموت والحياه في خير سول لكن
الجيش الاوكراني باتي يمسكوا بمقاليد
المدينه و يفاخر بان رايته لم تسقط
نتاشا تبدو سعيده هي وولدها بالانسحاب
الروسي من غير سول كانت اياما صعبه
بالنسبه لها
منيح
كما تشاهدون القصف مستمر لكننا لن نغادر
المدينه سنظل فيها حتى النهايه اغلب
المحال مغلقه وكثير من الشوارع فارغه
يحاول من تبقى من سكان استعاده حياتهم
للحصول على شرائح اتصال الاوكرانيه خلال
سيطره الروس على المدينه الزم السكان
باستخدام الشرائح الروسيه فرقت الحرب بين
كاترينا وعائلتها التي اثارت مغادره
المقاطعه في بدايه الحرب تبحث عن اي وسيله
للاطمئنان عليها الاتصالات في خير ما زالت
الشحن
دوشه جدا بوجود الروس لقد كانك الجحيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المدينه
على المباني
تحتيه ومنشات الحيويه لتحريم السكان من
الكهرباء والماء في وقت دقيق يشتد فيه
الشتاء
بنظري كثير من سكان خرسون فان عوده الحياه
الى طبيعتها لازالت بعيده المنى فالمدينه
تحت القصف المستمر واعمال الترميم تحتاج
الكثير من الوقت تمر صمادي الجزيره خير